[Applause]
three ukrainian families arrived at this
bus stop bruised bloodied and
traumatized
their youngest this one-month-old baby
born the same day that russia invaded
it's terrible she says we left
everything behind our city other family
members our heart
they are the lucky ones arriving here to
the relative safety of levive near the
polish border after escaping mariuple
they recorded these images of what's
left of their home
my sons are still there she says there
was nothing left but scorched earth just
hell that burns again and again their
escape from that living hell was made
possible in part by a couple of canadian
veterans we're looking at one of the one
of the places in here
keenan walper and dave lavery served in
afghanistan and until recently they were
working to help their former afghan
interpreters to escape the taliban
controlled country but when russia
invaded ukraine the veterans turned
their gaze to europe
we said we're coming out here right away
to see what we can do they've set up
shop on the polish side of the ukrainian
border sending aid in and getting people
out
including these two women who previously
worked as interpreters for the canadian
forces in ukraine
part of operation unifier launched back
in 2015 to train ukrainian soldiers to
defend against a simulated russian
invasion but they never expected to wake
up to the real thing i got really scared
like my my hands they were shaking so
much her hometown was one of the first
in putin's war path with russian jets
flying overhead and bombs falling all
around she knew she had to leave the
hardest part was to get out of sumu
it was blocked from different sides
there were russian tanks and russian
convoys everywhere so she reached out to
her canadian military contacts who put
her in touch with kenan i said you need
to go at the next opportunity but her
rescue required a logistical feat unlike
anything they'd attempted in afghanistan
she was trapped on the other side of
europe's second largest country you're
talking great distances here we're
talking you know 800 kilometers each way
and
obviously the risk is huge using
contacts inside ukraine keenan's team
coordinated a cross-country journey that
involved vehicles trains and multiple
bomb shelters along the way all while
avoiding air strikes shelling and
fighting after a several day trek she
finally arrived in poland and is now
working with the team to rescue more
former interpreters and other families
still trapped dave lavery says they're
just getting started we'll do as much as
much as we can as long as we can we're
here for the long haul one of the main
differences between their rescues here
and in afghanistan
is this
in ukraine the men can't leave required
to stay behind and fight
lavery met this family on the ukrainian
side the young father said goodbye to
his wife and baby
and lavery promised to look after them
somebody's entrusting you
with
they're precious
when you hand somebody your family like
that
[Music]
yeah it's gut-wrenching
even for hardened veterans the horrors
of this war can be too much to take
jeff sample global news la vive